[Music]
hello welcome to another episode of Ed
Tech unveiled the podcast that develops
deep into Dynamic world of education and
Technology I'm your host spot and today
we're going to explore a topic that
affects the lives of millions of high
school students around the whole
world the influence of technology in
your education during high school and
this journey will navigate through the
evolution of
Technology role in high school
experience its impact on teaching and
learning and the changes it poses and
the opportunities it
present Act One evolution of technology
in high
school to understand the impact of
technology on high school's
education it's essential to begin with a
a glimpse into its
evolution in the early 2000s High School
primarily used computers and the
internet for research and basic
assignments today we're an entirely
different
landscape where technology is deeply
integrated into the fabric of high
school
education one out of one the digital
classroom the first major shift came
with the advance of the digital
classroom traditional blackboards gave
way to inter inter interactive
whiteboards and multimedia
presentations students no longer solely
rely on
textbooks but also in ebooks learn
online resources and educational
apps one out of
two access of
information high school students now
have access to an
incredible wealth of information
online it's like having a library in
your pocket which has
revolutionized the way students research
learn and prepare
assignments act two impact on teaching
and
learning with technology grow growing
presents in high school the teaching of
learning methods have been transformed
transform let's let's explore thisis key
impacts personalized
learning one of the most significant
influences in personalized learning
technology allows teacher to tailor
lessons to individual students needs
adaptive learning plat platforms provide
content based on students
progress helping struggling students
catch up and advanced Learners stay
engaged 2.2 Blended learning the blend
of in person and online learning has
become the
norm the coid 19 pandemic accelerated
this shift with many high schools
adopting remote learning tools while it
presents
flexibility it can it also raises issues
around equip equipable access to
echnology to
technology act three challenges of a
tech infused high school
education as
technology cont continues to shape high
school education where are some
challenges that need
addressing digital divide not all
students have equal access to technology
creating a digital devide divide some
students may like devices or re re
reable internet access hindering the
ability to participate fully in the
stack infused
education screen time and distraction
The increased use of technology in
education has rised concerns about
screen time and potential
distraction finding a balance between
educational use and lecture is a
challenge many high school students
face opportunities and the
future despite the challenges the
influence of Technology in high school
education offers a world of
opportunities
4.1 virtual reality and argumented
reality the integration of virtual
reality VR
and argumented reality AR in education
is no is on the horizon
imagine high school students exploring
history through immersive VR tours
or disect dissecting virtual frogs in
Biology
class artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence can
provide real time feedback to students
identify areas where they need help and
suggest take aite
resources it has the potential to make
high school education more efficient and
effective Global
Learning technology enables high school
students to collaborate with peers from
around the
world virtualize ex ex exchanges and
collaborative projects expand Horizons
and prepare students students for a
globalized
future in conclusion as we wrap up
today's episode it's clear that
technology Technologies influence on
high school
education is profound and continually
evolving the key is horness horn horness
its power for the dynamic benefit of all
stud students while addressing the
changes to
create an inclusive and dynamic learning
environment thank you for joining
joining us on this enlightening Journey
Through the influence of Technology on
high school
education if you enjoyed this episode
please subscribe share and leave a
review and as always stay stay curious
stay engaged and keep exploring the
exciting inter intersection of education
and Technology until next time I'm Shan
signing
[Music]
off